the government response to the corona
virus outbreak has faced criticism for
being too slow in its early stages and
while several countries in Europe are
beginning to ease lockdown restrictions
questions remain over how the lockdown
could be lifted here well joining me now
is the former Prime Minister Tony Blair
his Institute for Global Change has come
up with some proposals on how this could
be done today and and mr. Blair
presumably if you come up with these
proposals it's because you think the
Boris Johnson government needs some help
well it's really is such a huge issue
and the Institute's been working on what
are the types of measures you might take
in order to ease the lockdown and how do
you do it most successfully because the
problem with this is I mean it is the
most complicated and difficult challenge
I have ever seen in politics so you know
I have every sympathy in solidarity for
people who are in power and taking
decisions this is our attempt not to
criticize but to offer constructive
advice how do you think they are doing
so far well I think you know as your
reports have suggested and I think
people in government would accept this
we were probably slow in the first
stages of the disease we're now in the
suppression phase which is absolutely
necessary really what we're trying to do
is to look forward and say the economic
and and indeed health damage of this
lockdown is so severe that we've got to
put everything in place now all the
preparedness we we need in order to make
sure we can ease the lockdown as much as
possible while still being responsible
about the spread of the disease and I
think this is a an extraordinary
difficult challenge and in the paper
what we suggest is ways that government
could be reordered around the central
tasks of this so things like the
acquisition of protective equipment mass
testing tracing in my view you need in
each of these areas you've got to have
the right senior person in charge
politician and someone probably from the
outside a lot of these things require
private sector not public sector skills
the right expertise in order that in
this preparation phase you doing
everything you possibly can so that when
you start to ease you've got the best
chance to get the economic activity
going I do want to come on to that in a
moment and I'm glad to say we've got the
time but I do just want to ask you as
things stand do you think we are at the
right point in policy terms of
continuing with the lockdown at this
level yes you've got to continue with
this degree of suppression until the
scientific and medical advice is that
you're on top of the disease now by the
way even when you ease the lockdown
you're going to find outbreaks I mean
all the countries that have eased have
found problems arising you've then got
to move very swiftly to contain those
problems and push it back down again but
no you can't you can't lift the
suppression prematurely I think we know
enough about this disease we don't know
as much as we need to know but we know
enough about it to know that its
severity is such that you you can't take
a risk and just let it run through the
population
I mean you've proposed that there should
be SARS or people in control of mass
testing of PPE of business consultation
of vaccines of school openings of tech
of tracing of shielding of international
travel of communications ten areas I
mean doesn't that run the risk of just
too many Chiefs running around no
because I think it's you know the way of
looking at this is in normal government
is you know Adam as well as I do you
know you have different government
departments right you have your health
department your interest you Department
your Education Department and so on
today the whole of government is covert
19 so it's and there are many different
facets and dimensions to it so if you
just take this issue of mass testing
mass test I can't see any way out of
this lockdown unless you do mass testing
and to do that and do it in the right
combination of the PCR test which is the
test that tells you whether you have the
disease the antibody test which tells
you whether you have had the disease to
do this in the right combination at
scale where you may be testing a
significant proportion of the population
I can't see how you do that unless
you've got a massive logistical and
procurement exercise underway so that's
almost like a government department so
I'm just suggesting these ten you know
areas where if I was back in government
today there would be a senior minister
probably a senior business person
alongside them with the right technical
advice doing absolutely nothing other
than just focusing a hundred percent on
that and the government in a way by
pointing lord Dayton who they've now
appointed in charge of the protective
equipment side of this I mean is in a
sense of recognition that this is what
you need but I think you need this in
many different areas I mean how do you
restart international travel again and
you know at the moment it doesn't seem
likely you can do this for several
months maybe but if you can't get your
airlines moving again and if you're a
country like Britain that depends on
trade and you've got busy airports and
you need people to come in and out of
your country what are the restrictions
you put around that what are the ways
you manage to do it safely these are
massive and difficult questions so I'm
saying that each of these areas should
really have its own almost like a kind
of government department working on I
mean most of these are questions for
domestic organization but let's just to
pick up on Airlines I mean it doesn't
matter what we say about Airlines it's
getting require international
cooperation isn't it to get Airlines
going again and there's not much sign of
that looking at the way the g7 and the
g20 been working yeah it's a good point
but I mean one of the things you would
do when you're looking at international
travel is trying to achieve that
cooperation because all countries are in
the same position and look what your
report I was just listening to your
report from from Cornwall and that's
just one you know that's that's one
County of the UK but you just think
about that picture which is pretty
devastating it is he cannot make
implications you think of that
replicated across the UK and then
replicated across every one of the major
countries in the world I mean that's
what we're looking at so you know it's
it's not yes of course you're going to
need global coordination around this and
one of the things I find shocking
the absence of that or the absence of
enough of it but you're also going to
need therefore the organization within
your own government to be able to do
that coordination effectively why do you
think it is that the UK the US and Italy
and France probably are those currently
worst hit by this this outbreak what's
gone wrong in in our societies it's
difficult to work that out I mean there
are explanations so for example one of
the reasons why South Korea and Hong
Kong Singapore got on top of this very
early was because they went through the
SARS outbreak back in 2003 so they they
were taught a lesson and they learned
that lesson and it's partly because we
have got you know populations that are
very global in their nature that that
that move around so in America you can
see the concentrations on the west coast
and the East Coast and you know there
are lots of different explanations for
it but I think there's enough experience
now to know and be able to learn some of
the lessons of this and that's really
what one things we try and do in the
paper is go through the experiences
about the countries and say look this is
what has worked and what hasn't worked
so for example if you take the next few
weeks because we're in lockdown let's
say for another three weeks you think
it's only going to be through their ass
kind of realizing if you'll be opening
up during that time very longer than
three weeks isn't it well it's three
weeks at least let's say so my point is
you've got the time to learn the lessons
of what's going on around the world
because there are countries opening up
so you're able to do that there are a
lot of lessons now about the best way to
trace so this combination of testing and
tracing there are a lot of lessons that
you can learn us the best way to do that
and then you've got this this whole
issue to do with therapeutics and
vaccines so we we are doing a lot in the
UK and we've got a very strong
bioscience sector ourselves in the UK so
we'll be doing a lot but their whole set
of treatments going on being
experimented with around the world
you've got to make sure that maybe we
invent
taxi that does this here in the UK but
maybe we don't you've got to make sure
that you are also in touch and connected
with vaccine analysis and the potential
for production of vaccine from around
the world I mean if you take Ebola first
of all by way it took about five years
to get a vaccine but secondly the
vaccine was actually invented not
surprisingly enough in Silicon Valley
but in a part of the Canadian healthcare
system so you know all the way through
in this it's just a very simple point
I'm making that right now okay forget
whether we were behind the curve or not
in the past right now we need to do
absolutely everything to reposition
government so that we can get our
economy moving again do you have a model
country do you have a country where you
you look at them you think yes they are
getting it right
I mean is it Germany for example well
Germany have definitely done well South
Korea is obviously a good example but
you know there's different experiences
on different things so I would say you
could look for example at South Korea on
the testing and tracing side in Germany
I think they've they have the advantage
they don't have as strong an innovation
in bioscience as we do but they have a
much stronger diagnostic sector so
they've been able to use that I think
one of the other things that we need to
look at is how do we start repurposing
some of our own manufacturing to produce
things like the protective clothing and
equipment you know there's a I can't
believe that we're going to be going
back to work without most of us wearing
masks I may be wrong that I think so
you're gonna need mass production of
that and on testing by the way you're
going to need to be able to test people
several times because there are problems
with both the PCR tests and the antibody
tests the PCR tests will only tell you
if you have the disease on that day
right which is obviously important that
valuable information but it won't you be
you could have the test on a Monday and
then find on Tuesday you you you get the
disease the antibody test is a very
valuable test
it tells you whether you've had the
disease but the evidence again is from
different ways of doing this around the
world that in the it's really a matter
of timing as to whether that test is
accurate or not in other words if you're
tested as to whether you've had the
disease or have it through an antibody
test in the first week or so the tests
are offered inaccurate after 11 days or
2 weeks they're mainly accurate you've
got a so all of these things are really
difficult to work out how do you combine
those tests together effectively you
know these are questions that we need to
be studying from the practice around the
world and that's why I think you've got
to have you've got to have this
concentrated firepower on each one of
these issues
why do you say we're not we'd all be
wearing masks I mean if you were Prime
Minister having looked at the evidence
would you be saying yeah we're gonna
have to wear masks or during it I think
you can't be conclusive about that yet
but I would say if you look at the
trends and again if you look at the
Asian trends particularly containment
masks have got a role to play and the
other thing is that they can often it's
it's not just that I think they do some
validity but I think they also will make
people feel more confident because one
of the things that this is one of the
other things we suggest which is why I
think it's right to be having this
debate now and to bring the public into
the into the debate you could lift these
restrictions and find people just don't
feel safe enough so for example you
could say well restaurants could open up
if they do X Y and Zed or some
restaurants could or we're going to
experiment in this area that if the
public don't feel that they're safe
enough saying with opening schools by
the way then they're just not going to
come so I think the the wearing of masks
may be it may be I don't know you can
conclude that right now but I certainly
would be looking at that and studying
that very intensely and very clearly
likewise how far you going to be quite
intrusive on the tracing and the use of
technology around that again the
evidence is that you need to be pretty
intrusive about it for it to work
effectively now I want to ask you about
responsibility you of course with the
whole
it's 9/11 and the Iraq war you were held
accountable and there was a public
investigation I mean if we have a
situation where more people died because
the government was slow off the mark or
we have a situation as we've had this
weekend where the government said we're
going to get a consignment of PPE from
Turkey and it doesn't come is it fair to
hold the Prime Minister and ministers
accountable for those failures which
have fairly drastic consequences well I
just think it's important in these
circumstances having having been in the
situation myself of taking difficult
decisions in government I just think
it's important to realize and this is
why whatever I'm saying I put in the
bracket of constructive advice not
criticism I mean this is a hellishly
difficult challenge there's never been
anything like it and so you know it will
be very easy to come along in hindsight
and say well you could have done this
you could have done that and and that
will happen by the way whether I think
it should happen or or not but I just
think it's important right now it
shouldn't be the focus of our attention
the focus our attention should be to
make sure that the next phase of this
which is the controlled managed revival
of the economy happens in the best way
possible but that is one of the things
we ought to prepare for is to learn the
lessons isn't it sure and I think you're
learning the lessons is always valuable
you know pointing the finger is
sometimes less valuable but it's it's
really that there will come a point when
you learn the lessons but I think right
now the only purpose of learning them is
to make sure you get the next phase of
this right and I you know by my
suggestion today and in the detailed
paper we produce about how you might
exit from lockdown we go through
different sectors and so on is you know
just this is so difficult to do
correctly that you need right now
because you have these few weeks when
the lockdown is going to continue right
now just identify each dimension and
make sure that you have the right
structure in place to deal with it
effectively